well there's plenty of curriculum
available but it's usually in different
departments go to the social work
department you know go go go go go look
at parenting education there's tons of
curriculum available but we don't put it
in in the business school uh and we need
to um a a course on active listening for
example you know we are terrible
listeners uh we're good at screaming and
yelling and we're terrible at listening
um the mere fact that there's even you
know it's even a thing it's even a meme
about how to get through Thanksgiving
because of your uncle who has you know
opposite political views at you and the
best advice we get is don't bring up
politics at the Thanksgiving table
that's nonsense how about learn to have
an uncomfortable conversation and learn
to listen and understand someone's point
of view when you vehemently disagree
with them and sitting down trying to
convince them is not listening trying to
understand and have empathy is listening
and when when two people with opposing
points of view can find Common Ground
that's where growth happens and I'll
give you a real life example from you
know in my life I have a friend um she
is from rural
Tennessee and uh we discovered over the
course of our friendship just how
Divergent our political views and views
on how the world works are to the you
know some of she buys into some you know
conspiracy
theories um and she and I went for a
walk once uh and we were talking about
something and I definitely thought and I
may have even said how can you be so
stupid and she stopped in her tracks and
said you just called your friends stupid
and I realized what have I done I'm
literally closing off any opportunity
for constructive conversation here
because I judged and accused even if I
think whatever Theory she's buying into
is not grounded in fact I I attacked
her and so I had to learn to take a step
back and embrace empathy and instead of
trying to convince her that she was
wrong or point out the facts that
dispute her beliefs i instead went on a
journey of learning to listen and
understand how she came to Bel in the
things she believes and during Co we had
many
conversations that were diametrically
opposed and instead of attacking each
other or trying to convince each other
um we got really good at saying tell me
more about that you know where does that
come from and almost always I could find
a fact or I could find a detail that
says you're absolutely right there that
is absolutely true and the minute we
could find Common Ground all of a sudden
we could build up from there and she
became much more open to some of the
points of view I had as soon as I could
affirm um uh some element in what she
had or find something I agreed with and
that skill of active listening is
incredibly difficult but immensely
valuable in finding coming ground um
especially with people with political
different political points of view but
the point is is you're going to have
disagreements with people about what to
what decision to make for the company
you know um you're gonna have you're
gonna have dis decisions about what to
do with a uh an underperforming employee
you know what what do we do you know
somebody who's resistant to coaching how
do how do we react you know like
difficulty is the nature of the game
there's nothing smooth about business um
it is an incredibly complicated uh uh uh
game that is it's a game of people right
it's all people customers are people
investors are people employees are
people like everybody's people and
people are messy and they're filled with
ego and insecurity and ambition and fear
and all the rest of it congratulations
there's your
company um and you know the best leaders
are the ones who who aren't necessarily
the best at reading the p&l the best
leaders are the ones who have who learn
and commit themselves to learning all
the skills necessary to navigate those
complications and in so doing building
trust from their team that gives them
permission to even make
mistakes